[Music]
now it's time for my second contender to
be put to the test such a wonderful
restaurant that my team and I felt it
simply had to be in the top two this is
Casimir in Bristol a fantastic Italian
restaurant now it's run by two young
brothers who today are the youngest
holders of the mr. Easton Britain I've
got some very very high hopes for them
in this competition I love this
restaurant because it's a family affair
mum and dad front of house and in the
kitchen two brothers creating cuisine
unlike anything I've ever seen in an
Italian restaurant really good
presentation unique brothers Peter and
John Ray are so creative and
experimental that frankly they make
Heston look old-fashioned
really want to take customers through a
new experience something special or
magical what I really like about these
two guys is their energy and their
ambition they are really seriously
pushing the colory boundaries out to the
extreme and they're still in their early
twenties you think exactly alike because
obviously it's two minds thinking on one
job we're almost like one complete
person if that makes sense
[Music]
YouTube I don't know if you're
completely bonkers or pair of child
geniuses the bird gastronomic instinct
which can't be taught or learned I was
proud of my voice from the very first
day that were born the first step the
first smile but now what can I say
it's just the proudest father in the
world but I can say that this success
has come at a price
Peter and John raised culinary dreams
are being funded by every penny of their
parents life savings we have to
sacrifice our retirement
oh yeah basically yeah it was a big
gumball I tell you what's a big gamble
let's hope Paco's paternal faith it's
going to be rewarded because Casa Mia
are about to face my first pressure test
I'm gonna hit them with 30 dinars all
arriving and ordering at the same time
[Music]
I'm like vanilla
they've just 2 hours to produce the
perfect meal for my special guests
there's a lot of me just want to get it
go in get the server site hopefully you
don't meet any mistakes today yeah is
about pressure
I'll be watching everything I'll be in
the kitchen I'll be in the dining room
I'll be missing nothing
you guys want a mission star last year
phenomenal today raise the bar again my
30 guests are about to experience an
avant-garde take an Italian cuisine will
they love it or wish they've just gone
for a pizza